i know you know who was upset with me
but it wasn't my idea and i didn't do it
it wasn't was uh
you don't want me to say this rich i'll
do from uh what's it called what's his
name
cordon yeah james corden
who's that upset yeah he thought that we
stole the idea because he he does
carpool karaoke but it wasn't even close
to that he wasn't no no but he's been
mad at me i've never been on that show
you have a lot of enemies
i do he gave a shot didn't he
yes he's leaving he's leaving
he's going to be doing i think he's
doing i'll make a call
have you been on that show no even after
you did uh our karaoke show no i'm
banned
i am too i don't know
have you done it since we did that show
i have not done it since we've seen
that's why that's why who i i would have
to check the dates i honestly do not
know i'll have to check the dates
because uh i'm telling you you're banned
from that show
you and i have been banned from that
show and you know who else i've never
seen on the show
any other contestants from karaoke
showdown no judy carter what she has not
impossible i think have you actually
talked to him has he said no i tried to
call him and he didn't he didn't return
my call he really i tried to call him
because i heard he was mad because the
network
uh posted something like because they
did karaoke in a car we weren't doing
karaoke in a car
we were doing like a game show we were
doing like cash cab and they had to
answer questions and you had to you're
the hardest job in the world i felt so
bad that was the network he had to drive
and host
and what what
what i have a story about that that i
don't know if i should tell you all
edited i'll edit it if it's not good
tell me the story
okay howie you ready for this yeah
so
we're doing karaoke this is the cold
opening right now
um
so the first day
i got the 11 a.m right
5 p.m they're like okay we're ready for
you
5 pm 5 pm yeah
that was the first day
so the second day
i got there we were a well-oiled machine
weren't we i got through 11 a.m yeah
and i'm thinking well they're probably
gonna be ready till four or five o'clock
yeah
i took an edible
howie
they were like
hair makeup i was ready for this like
what
it was hair makeup bro
bro they were ready
drive this gigantic van with two million
dollars worth of camera equipment
and they were like they were like craig
okay go ahead back up the van it's like
i'm looking at the cameras i'm looking
at my reflection okay okay stop moving
your lips stop chewing okay you know
what they came to me one day and they go
i don't think he feels well
do you remember that rich they came to
me they said i don't think he feels well
he's not he's not really responding like
he did yesterday bro
then i was like well it just has
transformed back to vanda because i'm
sure going to run this van into the so i
was
so terrified and anthony anderson was on
so we we sat down we were talking i was
just trying to keep myself together and
then they were okay quick let's go and
you know
thank god we were doing 25 miles an hour
somebody in front somebody back i was
able to go oh you haven't no i i'm gonna
leave this in
but i
so here was the thing we had such
technical problems so the first day that
the the network kept saying we need to
get i think we had like
i think it was like five million dollars
worth of
recording equipment we didn't know like
a james corden show
had nothing on us you know it was like
crazy and i said we don't need all this
you know i wanted to do it like kind of
lo-fi
i didn't even want you driving i said
you could be fun in the front seat let
there be another driver it was supposed
to be like an uber just shows up and you
get in and then we [ __ ] with you and you
go you're on a game show they made us
get this it was like a sprinter van yeah
which was like a mercedes and they made
us put like 20 different all these weird
robotic cameras and sound so much so
that it ended up like being five million
the reason that was the the first day
they [ __ ] up when they drove um the
whole thing overheated and all the the
cameras went down and they couldn't
figure out how to get everything working
the next day they go okay and this was
we only had one like if the if this
vehicle
got in any kind of accident or if a
camera went down or the electricity went
we were just shut that shut the whole
thing down so it's good to know that the
host
was higher than a [ __ ] kite on the
streets of l.a bro in 10 million dollars
worth and and i knew we didn't have any
more time to waste like i the first day
i didn't know that that would happen
right i just thought oh well get here
11. shooting oh you thought that was our
schedule
that's why
i was like i'm gonna just chill out in
the trailer you know and just were you
not freaking out on the street what
my freakout happened mostly before once
we got out there and got in trouble i
was like okay we're going nice and slow
you know i don't have to really make
decisions because you've got somebody in
front of me somebody backing me
um you don't have to make decisions
you're in a you're driving bro i mean
well there was that but i'm saying
was this
i wasn't like
i was driving but i'm following the the
lead car okay but you're driving i'm
driving and you have to make turns it
was you have to read the signs it was
the signals
and do a game show who was the guy in
the back he was so funny
there was some guy in the back i think
he's gonna be here later it might pop up
and do the rules
yes because you'd go
and we would say i remember the second
day
somebody said i don't think craig knows
the rules anymore
and i go how can he not know the rules
he knew the rules yesterday
how could craig not know the rules
correct and i'm one of them
i wanted to tell you so bad i was like
i couldn't let you know man i could not
it would have been way better you should
have told him but what would we have
done and we had a we had a like a guest
star we had anthony anderson is in the
back going to sing he's only there he's
giving us like a a two out of five
incredible doesn't wear off anyways like
you went to it but it takes you time to
get used to it like
i'm telling you but once we get started
rolling i was how many milligrams of
youtube
oh i don't remember what that was back
in the day back in the day i mean
because i had these things
like it was a lot in there but you take
a little sliver and i took a little slip
around like
here we go and it kicked in right when i
needed as you got into traffic
right before when i said back up the van
i was like
i'm gonna let the transport do that you
know that i remember that because they
said okay we're ready to go craig's just
gonna back up and we'll get out of here
and then i hear on the radio craig craig
doesn't want to back up
what do you mean craig doesn't want to
back up
can we get can we get a grip here to
back up the truck
what do you mean we're just there's
nothing behind craig he just he doesn't
want craig just doesn't want to back up
i'm thinking that's his thing
i will i'll take the show but i'll only
do it in drive
i will not do anything in reverse
do you know we had those conversations
oh
oh that's so funny
that is so funny and i remember that
they they don't feel good the guy that
was in the back
was a time who was in the back do you
remember who was in the back rich
he
there was a guy in the van behind people
he had to be under a blanket it was 180
degrees he has no idea that the guy
driving is stoned out of his [ __ ]
mind
it's like pineapple express in that van
in real time my friend oh that's so
funny
i'm glad you told me now yeah now it
makes sense about six years later
[Music]